yeah nothing quite beats getting a
brand-new Mac laptop especially the new
laptop smell but even if you've had a
laptop for the last two years it doesn't
have to feel alien rusty here are the
three things I did to get my Mac laptop
running like new again
step 1 do a really deep clean my biggest
problem was that I had very little space
left on my drive a free app called disk
inventory X helped identify what was
taking up the most space I then saved
those files elsewhere and deleted them
from the internal drive but there's lots
of junk on your system that you wouldn't
know to delete that's where Trend
Micro's dr. cleaner comes in I deleted
temporary iTunes files and application
cache files things already started
feeling faster number 2 kills some of
those unnecessary startup items part of
my systems sluggish performance was a
result of programs I don't use launching
when I boot up my computer in System
Preferences under users and groups
uncheck the programs you don't use on a
daily basis number 3 update your
operating system Apple is constantly
improving performance you can check to
see if you have an update in the App
Store and the fall Apple will release
Mac OS El Capitan for free it's supposed
to bring a slew of performance
improvements running like new now how do
I get you to smell like that